okay hello hello hello hello hello hello
hello welcome welcome welcome I'm
officially back from my tour which means
I'm back in Cincinnati Ohio and it's
time for a Korean lesson according to my
mom but what's this anyway so I'm here
to answer all your questions about any
mysteries that you guys have about the
channel and I'm here to learn some
Korean with my mom here we're getting
blasted by sunlight we're completely
washed out but that's okay because we
yeah so I am done with tour I'm still in
Cincinnati which means that I'm gonna be
driving back starting tomorrow I'm not
beer it's just yeah don't ask what it is
you don't need to know what it is if you
want to know what it is smash that like
button and you'll be told exactly what
it is so I'm gonna be driving back to to
Los Angeles from Cincinnati starting
tomorrow I haven't had a chance to see
cheeky yet because by the time I got
back to my mom's house here I know I
haven't washed that's how I and on tour
we don't shower we just live in our foam
filth on the bus for as long as we
possibly can and then we die that's
exactly how it works so if you think if
you if you can physically smell my stink
or see my stink lines through the
internet just smash that like button
well on that like button as hard as you
can smash it
real real intensely like yeah yeah the
sunlight coming through yeah Oh
someone's subscribed
I didn't see your names it's impossible
for me to know I have no idea yeah so
we're gonna we're gonna learn some
Korean and we're gonna review some stuff
also if you guys have any questions for
it I'll answer every single question you
have videos will be coming soon
oddly enough I do have some pre-recorded
videos I still need to put out but I
have to uh I have to record some today
while I'm still here but my first
priority after this even though my mom
demanded that I do Korean lesson even
though I was like mom please please
chicas waiting for me
she could meet me she's dying without me
please please please my mom was like no
oh yes yep
all that dirty bus food that I had
alright
you really learn some Korean hmm
explain my tumblr I don't know what's
going on what are you talking about oh
you strum here oh yeah this is the
tumbling yes in Korean as a universally
accepted is oh yeah oh cool mm-hm
oh yeah did anybody did anybody here
actually see me on tour and if you did
what do you think of the show because we
had an amazing run this time around
because we we are really in our comfort
zone this time we we hit our stride
because we've been doing this show long
enough that we're used to it and we you
know it doesn't really surprise us
anymore in terms of like unexpected
things but also we can mess with it and
number two like our improv is getting
stronger so that we're funnier you
didn't see us this time around did you
no no can I see
yeah I don't think nobody well that's
the funny thing we were recording the
bull show in Arizona we had a five
camera crew we had a jib and then we had
like four cameras and we we recorded
really professionally in the whole time
we had a cameraman following us and we
recorded like something for a special so
we're gonna be having a full fledge like
documentary style special and I don't
know what we're gonna do with it yeah so
don't worry videos will be coming soon
spread the word far and wide markiplier
is back I'll be recording videos today
spread the word so that people can run
and hide and power and fear because
markiplier is back damnit and when
multipliers back everything goes to [ __ ]
the tumblr here I think this is a pretty
good analogy like this is um like the
Toby's the tumblr okay this is the
tumblr the tumblr is placing right now
they're so fearful 1-9 you know why cuz
I'm back baby come back if you know I'm
back well on that like button is larger
you can if you want to sing the song and
ring the bell of Mark being back then
smash that like button and tell everyone
you know as far and wide as you can then
I'm back baby that's not even my maximum
loudness I know you it is 12 it is
almost 1 p.m. I guess now given that I
woke up at 11 but that was my excuse
because I was on specific time so now
you get it out there
you guys know what's up if you're ready
to learn Korea and put on your Korean
learning hats anybody speak Wien can
anybody speak Korean say yeah say yeah
yeah yeah yeah
most yeah you listen to kpop other
they're still wondering what's going on
with these tumblers okay so right like I
said this is things are called tumblers
so they're quaking with fear because I'm
back but you got to admit that they're
getting exactly what they deserve
you know whether they know it or not
they just only don't realize the
fragility of their situation and they're
just screaming into the void you're
right they are antique antique maybe
1950s mm-hmm that's wonderful yeah so
far past its prime right older is better
mmm no there's better older is better
makes sense to me yeah but could break a
hip at any moment all right now I might
yes I I have actually already recorded
all of Resident Evil and it was
technically already uploaded I just was
so busy I didn't even have time to do
the description or make the title and I
couldn't even actually go to there so
anyway yes I'm back so let's get to it
all right how do you say I'm back in
Korean come on you guys help him help me
I'm bad help me I'm back I'm back baby
I'm back
hey say I'm back baby I'm back I've gone
and now I've reached I was meda wasn't
me that what I was neither tora tora was
me that is all right
you know what I've been I've been away
from Korea almost over 30 years
sometimes I have to think tora tora
little goes here
Tarawa soil Tora Bora wasäôt
Tarawa Sunita Dora aah
no tour aah
I used up I last saw y'all wha
Oh your team sure to them it's gonna be
backwards but don't I'll show you oh I
say oh I'm bad baby you how do you say
baby baby yeah you know I'm back baby
yeah I'm brain into Korea yo Robin
you're born you're born
it says like them we don't say baby two
people so in song I go yo Bernice
Malaika hello everybody
if there's one thing that makes sense
when I go to another country it's that
I'm insulting so yo yo yo born like yo
yo yo born yeah
[Music]
so it's you know I saw y'all y'all Robin
I didn't McIntyre that moppy playa yo
one help me thankfully yes okay right I
don't right okay all right so next
all right let's skip through what I want
to do is like cuz we're gonna be going
to Korea when three months April right
oh really yeah wasn't that the
agreed-upon thing what I'm gonna do with
my football oh you're gonna put them in
a shelter
oh I think they're gonna be fine you
know what
that's your fault
you will be so City by the time I call
good
you chose to cook them unless I cook
every meal there are dogs they will eat
what I give them they make delicious dog
food now if you wanted to save money why
don't you just buy those dog food meals
that are like the pre-made meals pretty
many likes fine feeling cool put the
nose up I like this no it's a nursery
I served to my dog every dokkan it can't
be that every dog you get suddenly just
hasn't of this inane appetite for cooked
human food that's nothing I cook you
know for example yesterday I boiled
chicken Amish chicken right with the
onions garlic right you know you know
crackpot for two hours yep I'm gonna
crack I give old I took out all the meat
cable to my dog with rice brown rice
mixed and I'm expensive dry dog food
before I feed you and you ate the last
of I get the leftover soup I know
[Music]
there's something going wrong in this
house that's the situation
I get the leftover after the dogs get
their first pick yeah because they eat
the meat well of course they ate the
meat they'll also eat brown rocks you
just got to make a poem
they will what are they gonna die you'll
die
and your dogs will voluntarily choose to
die as opposed to eating my relative you
know chica chica loves her brown rice
she really loves it and she loves the
occasional snack human food but she
really likes brown rocks that's dog food
I mean they're brown how do you say dog
food in Korean hey Bob
okay Bob because he's a dog pop is rice
kpop okay like that
yeah top P ah
P yeah okay bullet gave up because gays
dog Papa's food is it one word mashed
together yeah okay so I'm going to the
store yeah mister store man may see I do
see are just G I just see you all day
everybody's uncle I just she's actually
I just I just see [ __ ] a mr. C I just
see kids on dog food please clean up
after sale okay Bob Jones you say oh you
know is that like if I want it I mean
I've eaten dog food before it's not good
but I mean I guess I could survive
you're asking question I don't use every
day so I'm trying to this is what Korea
I have my priorities straight number one
go get food for chica number 2 chicas
obviously with me in Korea not know you
take me to cut the career
thank you God danger yeah what's
happening you may be asking I'm back
baby wait your your the boon that
doesn't mean the baby's back like if
you're screaming like oh no the babies
back babies yeah yeah some like this but
I mean come on
[Music]
so came up to say give up to seal about
to say oh okay Bob
how do you say yeah what there's a lot
of like polite ways to say things like
really cool to see element yes yeah what
about like impolite please cuz there's
got to keep up Joe yeah tall that's an
order like okay so is kept up choice um
not not a little bit boom you take away
your what you say oh just Joe so is it
like Joe Joe Joe Claus so what's yeah he
says this it's all right cool Oh Joe
it's been a while it's been a while
dirty yes is a long time mmm-hmm my
leave you've been speaking Korean
writing it I guess is a bit of a
different okay alright that makes sense
all right moving on what's another
important phrase that you would say if
you were in Korea like there's this you
you get off the plane you're like where
are the taxis where where are the taxis
taxi so taxi all these Audis oh we're
actually not wow
you went on you were applied on taxi
right yeah taxi
riding
taxi
[Music]
okay yeah yes I'm hungry what you feed
me so happy so all I gotta do is ask
does everybody in Korea feed their dogs
first and if sighs yeah okay
so restaurants oh yeah Israel that idea
is oh yeah what else you want to know I
know you went to restaurant okay define
the present and a Oh to gaze at all of
how they all and go over there okay
cassia and you were there you find the
menu right you look at the picture okay
you could pointed it talked about you
want to say I want that okay tall God Oh
know what to say out oh my god do is
sale so like just say I do a lot of this
[Laughter]
bauble that's a very important word for
me for free they don't know very dumb
Margo how do I say check please okay
that's it
okay so talk about to say oh so you got
to say oh you have a menu right yes
ego you say okay mister be food and are
you eating kimchi
what do you isn't there something you
say before you eat like a way of like a
special way of saying thank you or
something oh I guess I'm there like so
you know what in queer public they don't
say thank you much thank you is
we're seldom news mm-hmm when they when
they give you a gift
okay say thank you about your new
restaurant mm-hmm
you you they are working for you where
you pay the money right so you don't
have to let's say thank you that's true
right I never said thank you anyway they
serve you whatever Romulus a lobbying
just hell I wanna live in say nam
youngjoo co i'm yun ji say oh they
brought me okay and you say oh if you
wanna say thank you but you don't say in
the public okay in Moscow
you take it okay you eat and then they
give sort of you small kimchi kimchi and
it was so good so you want more how
would you ask kimchi kimchi Tom more she
joins us ale Paw Paw Paw kimchi Tom Oh
dah dah dah dah dah you can say that QG
job before you they Michael alright man
all the food Korea really tastes like
spit I just say uh so they brought here
okay I didn't you'd you drinking water
they ran out she didn't pay attention so
we eat well how you get their attention
oh it's a lady or middle-aged lady you
know I'm not sure they're married or not
this man how you address a month has one
worker sir no is a woman lady whatever
girl ma'am no ma'am ticket man they
wanna they want everybody look
you see I guess II see FSC was that I
guess II was actually in all days mm-hmm
it was young lady but nowadays it
doesn't matter where you go in public
they've all want to be young lady you're
right I got good guy see I've got si si
si si si yoky all yoky I mean give me a
tent on your gear Here I am my visit to
Korea is gonna be so great perfect
everyone laughs at me here it will be
perfect like I said you want it bring me
some water
come on this is way more jobs you see um
[Music]
the little finger waggle that really
doesn't that seals the deal okay if
there was men young man old man
it's man it's a fifth year or 20 or 18
you don't know how the age how are you
gonna address them everybody's uncle is
there Oh
I've already forgotten oh no no oppai
he's more like a handsome young boy your
man because you're the man you watch
best man I just see Josie I just the
uncle wait I just ciénaga see a guy she
is a lady
I guess she I just I just see so uh
chopped pickle Oh cute oh I dunno cute
oh uh Josie see I just see ya I don't
see ya I just see in Korea young man oh
man it doesn't matter they were all
young man want to hear is and I just see
they don't care alright so now I'm fed
I'm watered I paid my bill oh no no no
you ate okay she's gonna say are you
done how's she gonna ask you what's
gonna say she's gonna say get the F out
of my store
hey loser just say are you done
[Music]
hi mama say oh hi Margo so it was that
mean more food no time in all o Paw Paw
Paw Paw mama so y'all Oh
ha ha ha myself hi more goes oh yeah oh
are you done Marcel how this all myself
and I say yes I say all myself go and
tell my busin Luda that you don't say
that between the family ok friend
so tomorrow said yeah check check check
check
kiss I'm so case and so guess I'm so to
say oh ok son so juicy oh oh you can say
check to say oh it's fine mm-hmm
actually you know what
in Korea we have the word check mm-hmm
CITC came here a check worth check
actually increase book interesting who
used to work before
we had a copy you guys are still
homeless probably that would make a lot
of sense what do you mean you guys I am
happy you guys what did I do the Germans
makes these guys yeah we are still
something from somebody
I'm with yeah exactly that's a nice ways
bottle right yeah but it's stealing
intelligence because you didn't pay
that's exactly what I do life lessons
with moms we're not drinking is just
plain cook no it's one a 1:00 in the
afternoon
time the slug back pure just like my
school mm-hmm they're developing like
this synthetic alcohol needs getting
legalized what are your thoughts on that
I don't know I'm not interested I never
experienced anything you know what I
mean don't go there mmm it's not worse
off trying my schooldays right if it's
not good if people say it's not good for
you there must be reason ok listen to
them in good here mmm just like smoking
well now people say smoke can cause lung
cancer whatever I wanna end this oh I'm
curious I'm gonna stuff your body gonna
reject my cup many many years okay hmm
and finally your body said oh I like
this weird thing chemical in my body
then you got hooked
like oh there you got any contradiction
is hot - alright so I paid my bill I'm
leaving I got in my taxi okay
she's gonna say I thought she's gonna
say it's only $60 $60 yes you pay you
know what's gonna do after oh they gonna
say I need you guys here all you guys
here in a restaurant you don't have to
say I need his hero they are working
right mm-hmm
say bye-bye okay
there must what are you gonna do now
still in the airport
all right but I know where to get a sexy
okay actually are these soils your the
entire what is a priority so tired
so again I'm in the taxi I'm like I need
to go to Seoul Seoul cargo now okay you
is a man and I'm in there the taxi now
you want to go you want to go to mom
don't let say cousin Naomi is one of
City
Oh No so gonna say to young don't walk
had to say well I asked him to can you
take it to Myeongdong how you gonna ask
taxi driver young man donates attraction
your uncle car go see car you little
okay no no no - Myung dong right yeah
the direction of hard eyes to go I know
under the direction of a pike oh you
have to put afternoon
how come you two syllable - no no not at
all Lucille also just Chi Chi Yong dong
little car to say so you're asking
somebody to do something or give it to
me right guys go good always particle of
director coming after direction yeah me
on the water ha no no no card you say oh
right
oh you want to go the long way Busan
Busan Busan Udo first so you don't have
to do that he's not so happy because a
long drive he's gonna make many
thousands so in turn to the Posada takes
about eight hours I think
mm-hmm all right so I admit it let's say
I'm in Busan okay made it to boot do we
have any family I have a friend there
where is most of our family water poor
Chinese are your sister strike down bear
come dressed there yeah it's a little an
hour above the South City 1/2 hour and
the US my sister Steve your aunt lives
or in Seoul City okay and my all my
family's relatives in the region who is
also the butcher and a friendly was a
near Pusan yeah sounds good so what do
you want to know I want to know alright
so I'm in Korea have you eaten
I'm there I'm tired now I want to take a
nap
we're in a bed Oh which method we're
better
I need a hotel hotel hotel so hotel jaw
well that's what hotel job Oh bleep
hotel
oh god yourself yes but in here what
tell no girl or you know or people
so what tell no Hotel hotel Oh hard to
say
hotel Hotel little patter all day long
because hotel Hotel has a little which
is patching so you don't have to put
little hotel oh what a long turn long
huh so he's gonna say what's your tell
how you say which water
it's what I tell it's so many hotel out
there right yeah so he's gonna say I
want the cheapest oh that's what I say
I've like cheapest dirt cheap hole in
the ground like my blanket is made of
mud I [ __ ] asleep on a bed of nails I
want my pillow to be made of porcupines
I wanna have absolute frigid air
blasting across from the Colesville in
an alleyway that's full of like used
hypodermic needles like full denim I
know he said I know that place oh where
you know why you might take where where
under the bridge we're in all days I
don't know whether still there house
beggars live under the bridge you know
why usually priest is has a roof and
also is close to water it's cool you can
go drinking water babe no problem I know
where it's gonna pay back for all the
crap I've been given everybody really
like they've all been colleagues or like
this Bob Bullock here like toss them in
the river he turns the car opens the
side door and I just roll down the hill
into the river and die that's my trip to
Korea another interesting factoid honest
a very inexpensive hotel right in Ba
Duba Jim dear Bobby sound pom-pom do but
what is ginger do you do so no sounda
sorrow what what happened there's a
place you can take a public path I have
anybody heard public baths have you guys
been to public baths they take a bath in
public in public they're all there they
have a Korean spa in Los Angeles no I go
sometimes yeah I think wash your body
pew pay its top 50 policy they don't do
that there no no no you have to pay
extra money you pay 10 buck bucks
Tim Donahue run
fifteen dollars for entrance then if you
want special service like body wash and
food they could ask me 50 bucks 30 bucks
just wash your hair 20 bucks you one
body scrub with massage hundred dollars
so keep that in mind guys if you want
the extra scrub you're gonna have to pay
for it but you know what it's not
probably it's not anything like a sexual
way if you go the inquiry you know what
I'm talking about
we are so culture used to taking baths
in public you know what I mean it's just
you know it's a kiss it's almost like a
market it's like how did people go there
don't get so happy of thought is not
male and female together you a separate
attraction male/female is boys if we
look like to be a go they usually mom
trying to take the point ladies whereas
because you know what instead they're
taking his best because mom usually you
know washed his son's body right I think
I remember that I have a vague memory of
going to the bathhouse yeah
the sauna big jaggedy like a hotel with
100 people
I remember that you have all muscle
swimming pool service and usually I want
to take my boy damn so I can watch his
body and they won't ask how old is it he
might be seven house oh he's only five
yes oh he's America and America that's
where I know I know Pablo from from my
childhood you drag around our American
Baba
[Laughter]
all right so now that we know the
essentials how to get food creep people
out call yourself stupid good take it
taxi to two cities way far away and then
get thrown under a bridge and then go to
a bathhouse and make an excuse for how
big you are
[Laughter]
yeah I think that's a good lesson for
today so thank you everybody for joining
me remember I'm back I'll be cranking
out videos I still need to drive to LA
but today I'm gonna be making video
strip over I still got resident evils to
put up that's all done then one over
video and then I will be on my way back
and I'm gonna go see chica right now so
thanks guys so much for watching thanks
Bob all thank you all right bye guys I'm
back tell everybody bye